[Applause]
we'll start with number
let's start with number 156 and then
have a virtual Press Room on Deck
congratulations Guillermo now your team
uh this is an achievement not also for
animation for stop-motion and also for
international crew and animators but
obviously I I'm also from Mexico so I
would love to you can talk about that as
a Mexican house for you and we also need
in the future maybe Mexico win best
animated movie but producing in Mexico
is something that we need to do so tell
me about your feelings I think we
started a stop-motion in Guadalajara
Jalisco Mexico where I'm from we started
in the 80s and it started with Roberto
Mora myself
we started to do super AIDS and we did
16 then we did 35 and uh for a long time
the anime was thinking I have been doing
extraordinary shorts and in Mexico City
I'm on the radar great animators and I
think it's important that we keep it
alive as an industry as an art form and
you know
um I have right now two scholarships
active for filmmakers and it is my
desire and my commitment now that I'm
gonna finance a stop-motion uh class in
government in the animation school for
Mexican students to go there and
specialize on stop-motion to keep it
alive
[Applause]
we have Canal 2 International
and Number 220 on Deck
bingo
hello hola can I do in Spanish is that
okay
okay wow
foreign what is this
okay sorry we're going back to Canal 2
International
it's a virtual question and then we'll
have number 333 on Deck
okay so I'm Stefan mimo from uh Canal 2
International you come over the central
Optical so first of all I would like to
congratulate you guys I know my question
is to know if it is possible uh for you
guys to share your experience with uh
animators uh from Africa and Pachuca in
Tamil
I didn't hear the question and uh share
your experience with uh animators oh
yeah um well I mean our animators are um
are Our Stars they're they're the actors
in our film and then they will never get
enough credit uh they really have to
breathe life into these characters and
we found some people who could truly do
that and they were just remarkable they
really could get in deep into the
character and understand what the
character was thinking and feeling so it
wasn't just uh motion it was emotion and
that's really and we and we also focused
on The Quiet Moments because those are
really important uh and animation isn't
all about big post-opposed movement it's
about really connecting with the
characters on an intimate level and you
you do that when you are with them and
you're quiet and you can look into their
eyes and you can see them processing
information
it also it's important that the
animation is done by people that are
have been given license to do so that
they were promised to be treated like
the artists they were and not
technicians and credited in the movie as
such they were created in the main
credits before even the voice actors and
our collaboration was truly a
collaboration between the directing team
and the acting team
all right great and also just one
addendum if you wouldn't mind um holding
up your numbers throughout the questions
that would be helpful and also if you
can announce your outlet and your
country before you ask the question that
would be wonderful
um we are going to move on to number 333
with number 107 on Deck the number of
the half beast
mini Beast
hi Jens uh Jasmine page Moore for the
academy and digital first aid just
congratulations down the board well
deserved um but this movie at its core
is about family and it's about love so
why do you think this story is so
important and impactual in the world
today well I think that there there are
several reversals in the film one of the
most important ones is that it's not
about a kid learning to be a real boy
but a father learning to be a real
father and I think it's a lesson that is
urgent in the world and same with
disobedience we are saying disobedience
is not only necessary it is a virtue
that that is urgent in the world now so
you know the the movie talks about
families while not in a constraining
perfect way as the cricket says an
imperfect father and an imperfect one
and how we can love each other in our
failures in our flaws in our Humanity
again I think that um almost all the
characters in our film eventually find
family in one form or another then then
there's real redemption in that and I
think even though it's ultimately a film
about sorrow it's also a film about hope
we're done yeah
we have um film critique which is part
of our virtual Press Room with number
149 on Deck 149.
critique
hi I'm Nancy Graham with film critique
and congratulations on your win
and one of the things um I wanted to say
Mr Del Toro that your movies have broken
the mold in terms of what genre movies
can do and the possibilities I wanted to
know what do you think that this win
will do for animated movies in the
future and the possibilities that there
I think that is not a single win we're
going to have to organize ourselves as a
community we have to have dialogue with
the guilds we have to have an active
dialogue with the academy uh this is an
art form that has kept being being kept
commercially and industrially and the
kids table for so long and it really is
a mature expressive beautiful complex
art form so a win helps but it is about
going forward as a community making it
strong making it known and say what you
what we need because the promise of
Animation can be fulfilled by the
artists that are in the Community
beautifully and young animators are
coming in all the time that want to do
this and they don't want to just conform
themselves to the rules and product that
is demanded of them
right and we have number 149 next with
number 390 on Deck
hello 107 over here Carlos aguilarious
River
I just wanted to ask you know you've won
the Oscar a couple times before but this
one's for animation what makes this one
particularly special well I think the
first thing is uh I think it was very
important for me to to have the chance
to say that directing writing our
Direction production design everything
we do in animation is analog as complex
or more complex than live action and and
the the desire to say that or craft as
directors is complex and important and
we know that and and
it should be recognized it should be in
the Forefront on this cause and all that
that was important it's great to have
picture director and animation because
they Define what I have loved all my
life since I was a kid
I want one for makeup effects one day
but it's beautiful and it's it will help
us Implement more movement in the
community in Mexico and in Latin America
to keep pushing for stop-motion which is
one of the most democratic form of
animation
all the other forms on our nation in
digital are too expensive but a kid with
a camera and a model in their in their
room they can do animation in stop
motion and it can say exactly what they
feel
okay we'll move on next to number 149
and then we'll wrap up with 390.
I like 390.
hey
Google
is
potente
Eva
the number 390 and also if you are going
to ask a question that is not in English
if you could please repeat the question
in English afterwards so everyone you
want me to repeat the answer in English
because I can what the [__]
what is important for Mexico and Latin
America to look towards animation is
that we can compete with creativity
passion an artistic Flair with anything
in the world and stop-motion allows that
for them to continue expressing this is
an important year for Latin America and
Mexico and animation the Festival of
ANSI in France dedicates is this
addition to Mexico we're gonna be there
and we're gonna push this message as
much as we can there you go
and now number 390 perfect thank you uh
Alex boys of America to your right
Guillermo you're right
um so this question is going to be in
Spanish so first uh because I work for
the Spanish division of boys of America
so
um
foreign
[Music]
diversity at the Oscars and also um how
these award impacts uh the Latin
American movie industry
Foreigner
multitude
so what I'm saying is that every time
you you stand to do a job as a Latin or
a minority or anything you do you're not
alone and the first duty of
representation is to do it really well
to do it really well because you're not
doing it for you you're doing it for
people that come after you and are
looking forward for opportunities and if
you don't do that you're closing that
door the things have changed since I
came here in the 90s I remember with
great Chuck green an interview I had
with German Navarro the cinematographer
that won the Oscar for Penn's Labyrinth
with a talent agent that said to him why
do I want a Mexican I have a gardener
and and there was a lot of uh open and
subtle racism that you have to move and
there is a glass ceiling the reason you
have to keep pushing it all the time it
it doesn't end with one generation it
doesn't end with one person but again
together you push that limit more and
more and create opportunity
[Applause]
no vemos gracias
thank you